ITS TIME FOR TERMS OF
SERVICE ENDEARMENT.
>> IF OUR LIVE STUDIO AUDIENCE
HAD READ THE TERMS OF SERVICE
FOR TONIGHT'S TAPING, THEY WOULD
HAVE REALIZED THAT WE OWN THEIR
CHILDREN AND THAT OUR PRODUCERS
ARE GRANTED DROIT DU SEIGNEUR,
THE MEDIEVAL RIGHT TO HAVE SEX
WITH THEIR SPOUSES.
>> THE WEBSITE TOSDR.ORG
COLLECTS ALL THE BESTEST TERMS
OF SERVICE FROM WEBSITES THAT
YOU SAID YOU READ BUT ABSOLUTELY
DID NOT READ BEFORE CLICKING
OKAY.
FOR INSTANCE, ACCORDING TO THESE
GUYS TWITPIC "TAKES CREDIT FOR
YOUR CONTENT" AND WE'VE ALL
GRANTED SPOTIFY PERPETUAL
LICENSE TO EVERYTHING WE
PUBLISH.
BUT WHO CARES, YOU ARE IN A
HURRY. CLICK, CLICK, CLICK, YOU
GOT (BLEEP) TO DO.
COMEDIANS, I WANT YOU TO TELL ME
AS MANY TOS THAT YOU WISH YOU
HAD SEEN ON WEBSITES BEFORE YOU
AGREED TO THEM.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND GO.
>> OPENING PANDORA RELEASES ALL
THE EVILS IN THE WORLD.
>> Chris: POINTS.
KEVIN.
>> USER AGREES TO A LITTLE BUTT
STUFF ON APPLE'S BIRTHDAY.
JUST A LITTLE.
>> Chris: BILL.
>> USER AGREES TO HAVE THEIR
BODY INHABITED BY THE GHOST OF
STEVE JOBS.
>> Chris: WOW.
>> THAT IS DURING BUTT STUFF
DAY, RIGHT?
>> OH, YEAH, YEAH.
>>Chris: MIKE.
>> TEN PERCENT OF PROCEEDS WILL
GO TO A FOUNDATION THAT GIVES
RACIALLY PROVOCATIVE TATTOOS TO
BABIES.
>> Chris: OH, YEAH, YEAH, THAT
IS THE KOO KOO KOO.
KEVIN.
>> CLICKING HERE PUTS YOU IN
TOUCH WITH LOCAL MILFS THAT
WILL SUCK YOUR (BLEEP)
CLEAN OFF.